[Music]
riverdale season 3 is almost upon us
and little by little we're getting more
and more hints about what to expect did
you know there's a rumor of a potential
crossover with another show stay tuned
to find out which don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up hit that
notification valve to stay updated on
newest videos and don't forget to check
out our community feature now let's
check out what's going on with Riverdale
season 3 we'll get a flashback episode
one of the more recent spoilers about
Riverdale season 3 comes directly from
the mouth of Luke Perry and Skeet Ulrich
they decided to spill some tea and you
know the tea is good when it comes from
the two resident hot dads according to
Luke his character fred is hiding
something in the past along with several
other parental characters we'll get to
see Betty Alice FP Fred and Hermione in
their younger form and Cole Sprouse will
be playing one of those characters Luke
even said that everyone has their dark
secrets and we're pretty sure this means
they're really hiding an important story
we're already here for it musical
episode the San Diego Comic Con panel
revealed that we're in for yet another
musical episode it's very rare to see a
show do more than one musical episode
and it definitely feels a bit weird for
a dark show like Riverdale there wasn't
much else on the musical episode but we
have a feeling we kind of know what it
will be about the first musical episode
embodies Kari and we have a feeling the
second we'll stay in the dark and
gruesome category stay tuned until the
end to find out about another big
episode three hint and a potential
crossover with another show it's a good
one answers lie in Season 2 episode 7
well at least according to the creator
of the show in May 2018 an interview
with the creator of the show came out
and
away with some interesting information
about season three according to Roberto
aguirre-sacasa you can get some hints
about season 3 in season 2 episode 7 the
actual episode had three separate plots
split up into characters Archie
Jughead Josie and Cheryl had a 48-hour
deadline to complete the black hoods
test that's pretty much all there is to
it but there's no clear answer why this
episode will be so crucial the season 3
will rewatch it a couple more times
though update on our fav ships the
Riverdale cast appeared on the San Diego
comic-con panel and revealed a few
things about our favorite characters yup
including our favorite ships we got some
news that bug head will be back Betty
and Jughead go back to their
investigative duo vibes from season 1
but things aren't that certain about
Varkey since Archie's on trial
Camilla Mendez said that barchi might
run into some problems especially with
the distance and separation of course
she didn't directly confirm that Archie
might end up being jailed but we have a
feeling his trial will be an important
part of season 3 Cheryl's power grabs
the same Diego Comic Con panel also gave
us an update on Cheryl it's been noted
that now that she's emancipated and is
officially with Tony she's at an
all-time high when it comes to her power
tripping personality a B&E with BNV what
would your Holy Roller mothers say about
this study Madelyn cash said that she's
going to start making power grabs
wherever she can but apparently that
won't go down so well well Cheryl's
bombshell is really going to give us a
bombshell this season we know she's
pretty much capable of anything
do you think she'll be around for
Archie's trial we have a feeling she'll
definitely do something that'll backfire
Veronica is an entrepreneur
we know Veronica Lodge is responsible
for one of our favorite internet
challenges ever
Karma's a [ __ ]
and it looks like she's banking from
that in season three
well not exactly from that the word has
it that Veronica's an entrepreneur in
the third season
Camila saw but she needs to make her own
money so she's really just hustling as
she's working at pops she's trying to
prove that she's not really just your
regular spoiled rich girl but she's not
only proving that to herself
she's also proving that to everyone
guess Veronica will make everyone do the
Hustle challenge in season three
jugheads mom and sister
we know that jugheads family is pretty
messed up but get ready because we're
about to see that interaction on screen
according to the creator of the show
will actually see jugheads mom and
sister jelly bean and justice Jughead
managed to somehow fix his relationship
with his father we feel like his family
won't bring any good news the Jughead
family duo will appear halfway through
season 3 around Episode eight or nine so
stay tuned
who knows maybe his mom and his sister
won't be as bad as they seem
we'll definitely be bringing our popcorn
though hermione has a new power of
course not a magical power
but as the new Riverdale mayor hermione
is enjoying being seen as the powerful
character of the town she'll be able to
make a lot of decisions and according to
Marisol Nichols she's going to use that
power to change her marriage we all know
Hyrum was arrested for fraud and
embezzlement
so perhaps her Maya knew might get some
revenge we can't wait to see potential
power trippy moves from Hermione in her
new role and we have a feeling a few
characters might be in a lot of trouble
because of it House and poly are in a
cult one of perhaps the most interesting
potential storylines of season 3 is what
happens to Alice and Polly their
relationship went through a lot of
turmoil as many mother/daughter
relationships would remember Polly
sipping her tea in season 2 finale when
Alice agreed to a friend's from the farm
coming over to invite him to come visit
and talk to you that sounds nice Polly
well it looks like the farm is a lot
more than just a farm because Alice and
Polly are caught in a weird cult-like
ceremony although this might strengthen
their mother-daughter bond we're sure
this plot will have some serious side
effects Sabrina
crossover in July 2018 we got a behind
the scenes look at the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina yep the comic book
version of Sabrina the Teenage Witch is
getting a reboot and it's directed by
the same person that created Riverdale
you can actually see the Sabrina and
Riverdale cast hanging out together
which is fairly suspicious considering
Riverdale has another musical episode
and their first musical was based on
Carrie could they do a crossover with
Sabrina it looks like we're not the only
ones that think so as rumor of a
potential crossover travels across the
stan world what do you think how do you
feel about River Del's 3rd season
come let us know in the comments and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]